scientists theorized that many millions
of years ago mars had rings just like
saturn
and it looks like the red planet could
be due for a new set of rings in the
future
how exactly would this happen
would these rings clutter up martian
orbit
and how soon would these new rings start
raining down on mars
this is what if and here's what would
happen if mars had rings like saturn
the four gas giants in our solar system
jupiter uranus neptune and saturn
all have ring systems surrounding them
of those
saturn has the largest
and mars could join the club
scientists studying martian moons phobos
and deimos suggest that mars could have
had several more moons
including one up to 20 times larger than
phobos
over billions of years these moons could
have been destroyed and become part of
an ancient ring system
could phobos and deimos be next on the
martian moon chopping block
if you're looking to cut something out
of your life it should be all your
unneeded subscriptions well with
truebill you can improve your personal
finances and manage your subscriptions
all in one place they can even cancel
unwanted subscriptions for you with just
a tap
you never have to get on the phone or
try and hunt down the cancel button they
do all the hard work for you and it
doesn't stop there truebill can also
help you build your savings lower your
bills monitor your credit score and
create a budget that works for your life
and you can do all this in one place
with just a few clicks
with true bill i reduced my credit card
bill in just minutes all i had to do was
upload a photo of my bill and they
negotiated it down for me and to help me
save for my 2022 goals i set up auto
deposits into a true bill smart savings
account they allow me to choose the
exact amount and frequency i want to set
aside and i can withdraw whenever i want
take back control of your finances today
by visiting
truebill.com
what if that's truebuild.com what if and
start achieving your personal financial
goals now
how am i in two cheese of the month
clubs
phobos is orbiting mars only about 6 000
kilometers from the planet's surface and
it's slowly losing altitude
eventually it will reach the roche limit
this is the closest a big space body can
come to a planet and still be held
together by its gravitational forces
for phobos the estimated roche limit is
5470 kilometers from mars
at this point the tidal forces of mars
would start to pull the moon apart
after breaking into carbonaceous
chondrite meteorites the stony rocks and
dust would form a thin dark ring around
the planet
you'd find that the smaller martian moon
deimos would still exist
that's because it orbits mars from a
comfortable 20 069 kilometers from the
surface
deimos would now mark the outer edge of
this new ring
this dramatic reshaping of objects in
mars's orbit could have a big impact on
any plans you could have to leave earth
and settle on mars
well maybe not your plans but more like
the plans of your future descendants
scientists expect that phobos won't get
ripped apart into rings for about 50
million years
the development of rings around the red
planet would be a challenge for space
flights
it would be difficult to navigate or
transport people and resources
even the most routine trips on or off
mars would become
hazardous rides
and a ring system would block some
sunlight having huge effects on our
human settlements on the surface
mars is already a frozen planet with an
average surface temperature of minus 63
degrees
so things would get even colder
let's hope your descendants brought
enough warm space suits
and even more danger would lie ahead
eventually all the objects in the ring
would come crashing down on mars
big rocks would leave massive new
craters on the planet's surface
if it's anything like what happens on
saturn
martian settlers could face massive
storms of rock and dust
falling to the surface at 10 000
kilograms per second
the future of humanity would depend on
our ability to create new technologies
to blast apart these falling objects
before they crush us
luckily for us this would happen
sometime between
1 million and 100 million years after
the ring forms
yeah we'd have plenty of time to come up
with a solution
maybe we could just nuke all those space
rocks before they crush our martian
dream
well
that's a story
for another
what if